pendant le confinement plusieurs ont
fait du pain sur les réseaux sociaux
les recettes se multiplient la farine
est alors l'un des aliments les plus
recherchés au canada les ventes de
farine ont augmenté de 200 8 % je trouve
que ça a été un bon côté du confinement
avoir envie de cuisiner de faire des
choses mais vendent expérimentés je
pense que les gens d'abord on
recherchait des recettes peut-être
réconfortante
par contre si cette habitude l'autre de
plus cuisiner maison de faire des faits
maison se poursuit je pense que le ses
locaux on peut peut-être passé innover
dans les sortes de farine quand vous
utilisez dans nos pains dans no more fun
dans nos gâteaux pour quand même que ça
soit nourrissant rassasiant et le choix
de farine et grands farine de lupin de
pois chiches de coco d'amarante de
quinoa de tef de châtaignes d'amande
jusqu'à de la farine de bananes vertes
et celle qui m'a le plus surprise et
contient des prébiotiques des bonnes la
bonne nourriture pour nos bactéries
intestinales
alors ce serait là un avantage ou un
désavantage de 70 nouvelles farine un
peu exotique
nous avons demandé à hélène baribeau
nutritionniste de classer et d'analysé
l'échantillonnage de farine fait à base
de céréales graines noix et légumineuses
un point positif la majorité de ces
farines contienne qu'un seul ingrédient
cependant il faut bien lire l'étiquette
car parfois il n'y a plus aucun
nutriment
c'est un bel exemple où on voit que zéro
g des nutriments qu'on recherche un
jeune farine longue zéro gramme de film
zéro g de protéines les farines typique
du régime sans gluten s'est souvent fait
à base soit de farine de riz farine de
tapioca fermes de pommes de terre
on doit être vigilant une farine sans
gluten que pas été enrichi parce que
c'est pas obligatoire et qui est à base
de riz blanc par exemple sera pas
nécessairement un bon choix
on va le voir entre autres par l'absence
de fibres au canada un règlement oblige
les fabricants de farine de blé blanche
d'enrichir de cinq nutriments pour
toutes les autres farine c'est libre aux
fabricants
donc c'est vraiment pour les gens ce
qu'ils ont entre autres la maladie
coeliaque ou des gens qui ont une
sensibilité extrême au gluten mais pour
ces personnes là ça serait intéressant
qui explore aussi les farines de grains
entiers sans gluten que sarrazin qui
n'aura amarante notamment
on ne regarde et où le grain complet ce
qui fait que on va avoir plus de fibres
et ses trois céréales sont
particulièrement riches en fer
c'est difficile surtout dans les
supermarchés de s'y retrouver
tirons de la poudre c'est un aliment
déshydraté écrasé c'est pas de la farine
c'est comme si je disais de la farine de
noisettes par exemple bah non moi je
vais appeler sa poudre de noisettes tous
que la poudre on l'appelle farine
finalement le professeur de boulangerie
hubert poinsot enseigne aux étudiants à
travailler et explorer les différentes
farines sur le marché les expérimente
plusieurs mélanges par exemple avec de
la farine de millet c'est les graines de
millet on en découvre année après l'es20
également le trail et beaucoup avec la
farine de miel c'est vraiment un goût
très particulier et très très bon si
vous aimez vous à vous en rajoutez nous
aller jusqu'à 15 20 % etc
et puis c'est toujours des expériences
constamment la boulange dit finalement
que ce soit chez soi ou même dans les
courbes
ainsi on ajoute des éléments nutritifs
par exemple dû faire avec de la farine
de tef une céréale éthiopienne des
protéines avec de la farine d'amande ou
de légumineuses comme l'effet vérole les
pois chiches le soya
selon lire l'entretien que j'analyse et
on voit qu'une bonne teneur en protéines
en fibres
il est une crime ans qu'on retrouve dans
la ligue ne laisse complètement aussi se
retrouver dans les farines des
légumineuses et farine de l'ain où nous
avons va va nous enrichir ça va nous
apporter des oméga 3 d'eau d'autres
vertus nutritionnelles qu'on ne retrouve
pas dans le blé donc plus on put aux
formes des mélanges
on fait déjà des recherches sur les
qualités nutritionnelles de chaque
céréales et après en deuxième on cherche
des saveurs originales comme la farine
de coco on a développé des biscuits avec
tout le plaisir l avantage des farines
de coco c'est l'art teneur élevée en
fibres
on ne retrouvera pas non plus beaucoup
de glucides
plusieurs de ces farines permet
d'augmenter notre apport en fibres
quand on sait que l'on consomme
quotidiennement environ la moitié de nos
besoins
on dit qu'un apport adéquat serez entre
25 30 g de films par jour qu'on est plus
autour de 10 15 20 g de fil par jour de
recherches est donc une teneur en fibres
idéalement le qui serait de 2 g par
portion de 30 grammes
donc ça serait un barème qu'on pourrait
comprendre à chercher comment c'est de
mélanger 50% de femmes blanches il 50%
de faire une intégrale ou à retrouver
on va déjà être un bon progrès ensuite
se diriger vers le 100% intégral tout
doucement dans ce qui concerne l'ajout
de faire une sans gluten on commence
progressivement on peut commencer 10%
avec toutes sortes de faire une prime
aux boulets et ensuite 20 30 etc
on peut faire du pain en soit hier on
peut faire du pain farine de riz on peut
faire du pain à tous finalement y'a pas
de limite dans cette place de pâtisserie
du terroir le professeur tribu fait
déguster à ses étudiants différents
ingrédients dont la farine
les élèves sont en train de démystifier
les différentes sortes de fer rennes on
en avoir on allait sarrazin il existe
aussi des farines sont peut-être plus
difficiles à trouver comme le
topinambour et en partie si on peut se
permettre par exemple de faire une pâte
à tarte au sarrasin on a intégrant deux
tiers de sarrasin est ce qui serait pas
possible pour un pain
pour choisir il y à aussi pourri si le
terroir on a quand même le désir
d'encourager nos producteurs hockeyeurs
locaux
on va axer surtout sur des des produits
qui sont dans un rayon de 50 à 80 km des
quais donc jusque récemment on avait
surtout des farines très blanche
on a oublié le côté nutritifs pour son
mari vers le côté visuel doublèrent du
super peps blanc tranché aujourd'hui les
étudiants rencontrent un agriculteur
c'est dans notre philosophie d'essayer
de de transparaître la passion une autre
passion du métier de l'agriculture et de
la meunerie aux élèves qui sont les
futurs ambassadeurs des frn artisanat
souvent plus chers et sans agent de
conservation ces farines peuvent
facilement rangs serrés se gaspille
explorer l'univers des farines tout en
découvrant ce qui se fait ici
selon rudy donne les qualifications au
poids du dégoût au point de vue de la
texture au poids du de tout ce qui est
nutritionniste c'est complètement
différent
et puis je vous dirais on est dans l'air
du temps là on a compris
encourageons les productions locales ou
si je pense que c'est un devoir de
société